irani ins take to the streets to protest
their dirtbag terrorist leaders in
exactly the way conservatives predicted
they would and in direct opposition to
two weeks of leftist howling we will
examine how Trump got it so right and
why reality contradicts the left's
international worldview then Bernie
takes the lead in Iowa just 20 days
before the caucuses just before the next
democratic debate Democratic Party
elites are furious I for one could not
be happier then brexit Mex it in the
passing of the great conservative
thinker of our age all that and more i'm
michael knowles and this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to let's just recap the
last two weeks real quick the left told
us that Trump initiated war with Iran by
killing their military leader and
frequent terrorist Qasem Soleimani the
left told us that killing sulamani would
usher in World War 3 the left told us
that this heightened conflict will unify
the Iranian people behind their mullah
terrorist regime and totally undermine
American objectives in the region and
really put us at a disadvantage in
reality none of that happened none of it
not any of it not one little piece in
reality the exact opposite of that
happened the perfect opposite for one
Donald Trump did not start the conflict
Iran started this conflict in 1979
actually but in recent days they had
been attacking our embassy in Baghdad
which was the straw that broke the
camel's back they had killed an American
contractor over there for the past 15
years they've been killing 600 US
servicemen just kissimmee sulemani is
responsible for killing 600 US
servicemen they started it they've
provoked it they took our sailors
hostage Barack Obama bent over and sent
them pallets of cash Donald Trump did
not send them pallets of cash he sent
them a drone and took out their top
military leader so Trump did not start
the conflict he did respond to the
conflicts then did that cause World War
3
no actually our retaliation against
Iran's provocation deterred further
aggression in response to the killing of
their top military guy they loved some
ballistic missiles into the dirt and
they didn't kill a single American or
even a single Iraqi on those military
bases that they targeted then did the
heightened conflict unite Iran's people
behind the mullah government not even
close the the heightened conflict led to
mass Iranian protests in the streets of
their own government and
their government started shooting at
them they said the enemy is here the
enemy is not America the enemy is here
they were chanting this so the the
Iranian retaliation against America for
killing sulemani purely symbolic it
accomplished absolutely no hard
objective actually a completely backfire
right cause it spurred all these
protests in the streets now there was a
strange event in the retaliation no
American servicemen killed no Iraqi
servicemen killed but at the same time
as this retaliation was going on a
ukrainian airline crashed looked like it
was shot down iran said that it was a
fire and a mechanical error on the plane
that accident that plane crash seems to
have been the straw that broke the
camel's back in iran because that is
spurring all of these mass protests
we'll get to what that means in a second
not just for iran but for the united
states and the whole world but first
I've got to thank our friends over it's
zip recruiters zip recruiter sends your
job to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards but they don't stop there with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job so
look we have a lot of really talented
people here at the Daily wire we have
some not so talented people I'm not
gonna say their names on air but you
know with those people you wish we'd use
zip recruiter for the majority of people
though the zip recruiter has been such a
big help why because you're not just
throwing spaghetti at the wall and
saying oh gosh I hope someone finds my
job posting they go out there they find
them for you they analyze each applicant
they spotlight the top candidates you
will never miss a great match zip
recruiter is so effective that four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a high quality candidate
through the site within how long a month
a week one day one single day and it's
so important time is money you got to
fill these spots especially when you're
growing your business right now my
listeners can't read zip recruiter for
free at sip recruiter comm slash Knowles
that zip recruiter dot-com slash Knowles
zip recruiter comm /ko wles
zipper career the smartest way to hire
you had a totally symbolic retaliation
from Iran and yet this airplane crashes
initially Iran says this has nothing to
do with our retaliation against the
Americans it's a total accident yeah we
don't know how this plane crashed oh by
the way we're not going to give you the
black box please stop looking into it
please go away
then they accept responsibility so Iran
says yes the plane was accidentally shot
down these these idiot mullahs shot down
this commercial plane because they
couldn't identify it and they worried
that it was an American plane or
something to that effect
totally Iran's fault right
they start the whole conflict the United
States responds in a really targeted way
kills their top terrorist chief no
collateral damage whatsoever and then
Iran responds and lob some missiles into
the dirt and accidentally kills 187
people hundred seventy six people on
this Ukrainian airline completely iran's
fault beginning to end right well that
wasn't what the regime said javad zarif
who is the foreign minister of iran and
also John Kerry's BFF tweeted out quote
a sad day preliminary conclusions of
internal investigations by Armed Forces
human error at time of crisis caused by
US adventurism led to disaster our
profound regrets apologies and
condolences to our people to the
families of all victims and to other
affected nations obviously absurd only a
complete hack whose brain has been
totally eaten away by political
opportunism and hatred of Donald Trump
could possibly utter such a statement
could possibly think that the US has any
responsibility for Iran starting a
hostility and then shooting down a
commercial jet right so therefore we
turn to Peabody Judge Pete Buddha jej
says pretty much exactly the same thing
that your buddies Arif said people to
judge tweets out quote innocent
civilians are now dead because they were
caught in the middle of an onion
sorry and unwanted military tit-for-tat
my thoughts are with the families and
loved ones of all hundred seventy-six
souls lost aboard this flight
unnecessary and unwanted military
tit-for-tat unwanted by whom
Iran started the thing they started it
years and years ago but in this recent
altercation they started at a few weeks
ago so they wanted it did we want it we
don't we don't want to be attacked but
if we are attacked we're going to
respond so is it people to judge is
saying it was unwanted Iran didn't want
this
what no none of us wanted this no Iran
obviously did want this that's why they
started it unnecessary what do you mean
unnecessary so if if a foreign hostile
foreign country that's trying to acquire
nuclear weapons that's been killing our
servicemen for 15 years if they attack
our embassy try to give us another
Benghazi and kill an American contractor
in recent weeks it's unnecessary to
respond is that what people judge is
saying what moral idiocy what total
moral blindness what total geopolitical
ignorant unsurprising from Mayor Pete
the twelve-year-old local mayor of South
Bend Indiana who's probably gonna get
thrown out by the voters in his own tiny
town that's why he's got to jump and try
to become president first but but the
the real moral idiocy here is parroting
Iranian propaganda against your own
country really really bad look
fortunately though the people of Iran
have much more moral clarity than Pete
Buddha judge because the people of Iran
aren't gobbling up that that mullah
propaganda like he is the people of Iran
are taking to the streets not to protest
the United States not to protest Israel
not to protest any of the boogie men
that the mullahs usually throw out there
the people of Iran took to the streets
to protest their own regime and
President Trump is handling that
situation in a very very smart way we
will get to that in one second first are
going to thank our friends over at
LifeLock what is a New Year's
illusion that is easy to keep going to
the gym probably not eating better now
if you like me I don't think so but you
can resolve to help protect your
identity and personal info with life
lock identity theft protection life lock
alerts you to potential threats to your
identity they see more than what you can
see by just monitoring around your own
credit they see your info on the dark
web for instance how often are you going
onto the dark web hopefully not very
much if you have a problem life locks
us-based restoration specialists know
the steps to take to help resolve your
case guys this is a no brainer protect
your identity only one in five identity
theft victims who had accounts opened in
their name discovered their theft
through a bank or a credit card company
you cannot rely on the credit card
company to call you okay now of course
no one can prevent all identity theft
erm honor all transactions and all
businesses but life lock is the new
year's resolution that's not only easy
to keep it will help you protect what
you've worked so hard for get life lock
for up to twenty five percent off your
first year I love these guys I trust
them to protect my identity you should
to take this seriously as big tech as
everybody is throwing your information
to the wind and your data and your
identity go to LifeLock comm slash
Knowles canna wles LifeLock comm slash
Knowles k no wles
for up to 25 percent off so iran's
iran the citizens are taking to the
streets here we've got a little bit of a
clip of it the they're taking to the
streets obviously I don't speak Farsi I
suspect you don't either but what the
translators are saying is that they are
chanting we are not the enemy of the USA
and Israel our enemy is the Islamic
Republic of Iran
there were people chanting death to the
regime they were chanting people
chanting to overthrow the regime and how
is Trump responding to this every time
Trump responds in any way to world
affairs the left says he's gonna cause
World War 3 well it's gonna be tougher
for them to spin this Trump tweets out
for tweets in Farsi right so it's this
is being tweeted directly to the Iranian
people making the mullahs shake in their
boots or what
or whatever they wear he tweets that
first quote to the brave and suffering
Iranian people I have stood with you
since the beginning of my presidency and
my government will continue to stand
with you we are following your protests
closely your courage is inspiring now he
was mocked for this by some of his
critics on the left and even on the
right they said wait a second last week
you were threatening to blow up their
cultural sites now you're saying you
stand with them yes of course of course
he stood with them since the beginning
how is he stood with them by attacking
their regime with the right has been
saying from the beginning is that there
is a difference between the Iranian
people and the Iranian regime and the
Iranian regime is weak and the the
Iranian regime has to kill protesters
1000 at a clip because of how unstable
their position is they have a terrible
economy they've got terrible beliefs
they are unpopular in the country that's
what the right believes what the left
believes is that the regime is very
popular there's no light between the
Iranian people and the Iranian regime
we've got to deal with the mullahs
because that's the only way that we're
going to deal effectively with the
country
fundamental difference of opinion here
it would seem that Trump is right it
would seem that these protests are
saying Trump is right you know Obama in
during his presidency he had the
opportunity especially 2009 to support
the Iranian people who were rising up
against their government he didn't do it
it was such a cowardly act the United
States seemed as though they were
innocent worth of protesters in the
Green Revolution and then they didn't
then the u.s. kind of backed away all
those guys got slaughtered so Trump is
clearly picking a side here and he
picked a side since the beginning of his
campaign he tweets that again in Farsi
tweets that again in Farsi he tweets out
a fourth time in Farsi this time he's
directing this right at the mullahs he
says the National Security Advisor said
today that the sanctions and protests
have put Iran under great pressure and
forced them to negotiate in fact I don't
care if they are negotiating it's up to
them but don't have nuclear weapons and
don't kill your protesters simple enough
I love this response I don't want to
negotiate with Iran I don't care what
the mullahs do I don't care what they
have to
they're proven liars their word is
absolutely without any credibility no no
negotiation I don't even like the idea
that we're negotiating with these
dirtbag terrorists I don't want to sit
at the same table as them now the Obama
approach was I'll talk to anybody in
many ways the Trump approach is also I
will talk to anybody because every
meetings with Kim jong-un at least when
it's strategically advantageous but
Trump is done negotiating there there is
a time to negotiate and there's a time
to start killing their top generals and
it would appear that we are in that
latter stage you know there are
different different groups in the State
Department of Defense Department the
Armed Services right now some people
their job is to go to foreign countries
and to speak and to negotiate some
people their job is to go to foreign
countries and pull the trigger and shoot
guns it would appear that we are now in
that stage Trump is simply telling Iran
without any qualification without any
condition don't get a nuclear weapon
don't kill your protesters the
implication being if you do that we're
gonna start wrecking your country again
we just killed one of your top guys who
could have been a leader of Iran we're
imposing crushing sanctions on you which
Ilhan Omar while she's crying over
sulemani is saying is economic warfare
right so we are taking a very tough
tough stance on Iran and Trump is saying
we're not going to negotiate this is not
like a okay well maybe you can kill some
protesters but not all your protesters
no don't do it the time for negotiation
is over John Kerry is so upset about
this because it make this makes him look
like such a fool look at what we've got
here we have somehow come out of this
Iran hostility with the best-case
scenario we have deterred Iranian
aggression when they shot those
ballistic missiles in the dirt that was
the proof of that we've deterred Iranian
aggression we've taken the biggest
terrorists in the world off the board a
while ago we took off Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi the head of Isis then we
took Qasem Soleimani then at the time of
his death the biggest terrorist in the
world off
bored then we took out his deputy from
Hezbollah he was he was there as well we
blew him up as well so worse terrorists
in the world off the board and we're
encouraging the Iranian people to
protest what is the most dangerous
regime in the world and by we I mean
Trump Trump did it you got to give the
guy credit where credit's due
I've criticized Trump when he passes
some law that I don't like you know I
the first step act he passed last year
really drove me crazy but when when I'm
considering the things that Trump has
done that's driven me crazy it's like
four things and they're relatively minor
issues compared to this incredible
handling of the Iran situation I mean
you've got to keep your priorities in
order and I think a lot of the criticism
of Trump on the right is people who
don't really have a sense of their
priorities this was pretty incredible
and one way that we know it's incredible
you got to get your tumblers out for
this one is reading John Kerry's
reaction to it John Kerry published an
op-ed in The New York Times and the
title of the op-ed I kid you not the
original title was Trump has destroyed
what we built Isis what it does he
destroyed he destroy Isis the unity
behind the mullahs yeah yes he destroyed
that a bunch of stupid international
Accords that didn't do anything and gave
up our sovereignty yeah he'd guess he
destroyed that your terrible economy
yeah you guys he destroyed that right he
did destroy what you built whatever
happen to Barack Obama to remember
Barack Obama said you didn't build that
things you think you built you didn't
build that well they did build all of
these terrible institutions that Trump
has that ripped down he's ripped down
the Obama legacy that's what he's done
Trump has ripped down the Obama legacy
now it looks like he's ripping down the
opportunities for the Democrats to
retake the White House and you don't
need to take my word for it look at the
polls massive new poll massively
important new poll out of Iowa for a
while you had a four-way race in Iowa
between the top Democratic contenders
now Bernie is pulling ahead
and the reason these poles are really
starting to matter is we are twenty days
away from the Iowa caucuses bernie is
now in the lead he's passed the margin
of error
he is a a clear leader even though it's
still a close race
Bernie's ahead and the Obama Democrats
are freaking out a new Des Moines
Register CNN mediacom Iowa poll Bernie's
at 20%
Warren is at 17% Pete Budaj
who had been at 25% he had that Budaj
edge meant him he was way up he dropped
nine points Buddha judges and free fall
he's down to 16% poor old Joe Biden at
15%
why is Bernie surging he's surging
because he's genuine he's genuinely
awful he's genuinely a socialist his
ideas are genuinely indefensible his
life is genuinely undistinguished he
genuinely didn't really have a job until
he was like 40 but he is genuine he is
the real deal he almost certainly knew
Karl Marx when when he was a young man
he almost certainly knew Stalin when
they were hanging out at bars in Russia
he is genuine and he's offering a
genuine alternative to his colleagues in
the Democratic field and and even to
Trump Bernie is so attractive to a
certain segment of the left
he's even got one of the hottest chicks
in the world to endorse him the model
Emily Ratajkowski Emily Ratajkowski
who is in almost every way the opposite
of Bernie Sanders he's old she's young
he's not terribly physically attractive
she's one of the most attractive women
in the world
he is a millionaire she's also a
millionaire I guess they're both
millionaires I'm seeing a threat here
with socialists here is Emily
Ratajkowski
endorsement of Bernie Sanders hi I'm
Emily Ratajkowski and I'm endorsing
Bernie Sanders for president I'm 28 I'm
a millennial a true millennial you know
I think one of the things that's so
interesting about
young people supporting Bernie Sanders
is that he's not like a young sexy
candidate what he says speaks so much to
what people want but sort of who he is
it's so much beyond just one man Bernie
is extremely genuine he's consistent
he's powerful not because of who he is
as one person but because of the way
that he invigorates people and excites
them and brings together this movement
so when Bernie sort of popped up on the
radar as this guy who had been arrested
in the 60s and had been consistent in
his policies not only has he always
advocated for health care he's also
always been on the right side as far as
civil and humanitarian issues all right
there's a lot to digest in that crazy
statement but it tells you a lot
actually that statement tells you a lot
why do young people like Bernie Sanders
broadly why are young people
identifying with socialists you know
there are polls that come out every so
often that the majority of Millennials
identify as socialists the good news is
only a minority of them can define what
socialism is but socialism is on the
rise in a way that would be unthinkable
10 or 15 years ago why well in part it's
because their parents are baby boomers
their parents were the radicals of the
1960s in part it's because they've had a
K through college education that has
prepped them to veer steadily to the
left in part it's because they were born
in many cases after the fall of the
Berlin Wall they don't remember the
horrors of communism and by the way even
during the Soviet Union even during the
those awful awful decades of communism
the Left denied it and the American Left
has never really apologized for their
support of communism abroad but I think
the fourth reason gets to the essence of
the difference between conservative and
leftist political philosophy we'll get
into the conservative point a little bit
when we talk about the passing of that
great conservative thinker Roger Scruton
which is for conservatives there is a an
intrinsic limiting principle on our
political ideas to be
conservative is to be fundamentally
politically humble right a Michael
Oakshott the British Conservative
philosopher said that to be conservative
it's not just about free markets and low
taxes and small government and keep your
gun and go to church right it's not just
that it's to prefer the tried to the
untried the familiar to the unfamiliar
the bound to the unbound the limited to
the limit less present laughter to
utopian bliss we want to conserve things
we don't want to run crazy
we know our political ambition is not
that high we we believe in human nature
we don't think you can perfect human
nature we think we're fundamentally
broken we think we're fundamentally
flawed we're not going back to the
Garden of Eden there is a limit to what
politics can accomplish and that is why
we need to cultivate virtue and
ourselves and have a thriving civil
society and have voluntary associations
and limit the government's power because
guess what we're not governed by angels
that's it because that conservative view
is so humble in the face of the prospect
of politics we generally don't get out
ahead of our skis for the left there's
no limiting principle what's the
limiting principle on the left if you
start in kind of 1960s America with the
premises of the sixties that Western
civilization is bad hey hey ho ho
Western Civ has got to go the political
establishment is bad we need to over
America's racist America sexist America
is bigoted America is bad our history is
bad our founding fathers are bad if you
start with those premises that you hate
your country and you don't want to
conserve any of it then what's the
limiting principle why would you ever
stop if you if you begin with the
premise that mankind is perfectible and
we're so close to utopia on earth if you
only elect me as Barack Obama said the
sea levels will decline the earth will
begin to heal speaking like he's got
apocalyptic visions or you know he's
going to reinstitute the Garden of Eden
if that is your premise there's no limit
and so it doesn't matter how moderate
relatively Democrats of the 70s or 80s
or 90s looked it was ever thus if you
begin with the premises of leftism you
were gonna run away into radicalism
we're seeing the fruits of that now and
Bernie Sanders is the embodiment of it I
mean he is an old codger whose time has
come
Bernie's been around forever he was
around st. Petersburg when he felt there
was time for a change
and yet he's just lasted so long that
the Democratic Party has finally caught
up with his leftist radicalism the Obama
Democrats don't forget Obama was a
radical to the Obama Democrats are
terrified about this Liz Warren is
terrified about this Nancy Pelosi is
terrified about this we'll get to all of
that we'll get to some good news and
brexit we'll get to some bad news and
mix it we will get to the passing of
that great conservative thinker Roger
Scruton first I got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube head on over to
daily wire.com you get me you get the
Andrew Klavan show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh show
you test questions in the mailbag coming
up on Thursday you get another Kingdom
you get the John Kerry tumblr it's also
known as the left is tears tumblr but
this week this week it is known as the
leftist tears tumblr weird weird you
pick it up you know and and you walk up
to John Kerry's on the phone he says
Javad Javad I'm sorry about sulemani I'm
so sorry Javad the tears fall in and
then you drink them and you have a
lovely afternoon go to daily wire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
so the left-wing Democratic radicals of
yesterday
meaning the Obama team are terrified of
the left wing radicals of today led by
Bernie Sanders Jim Messina who is Barack
Obama's 2012 campaign manager just came
out finally tried to stick the knife in
the Sanders campaign he said quote if I
were a campaign manager for Donald Trump
and I look at the field I would very
much want to run against Bernie Sanders
I think the contrast is the best he can
say I'm a business guy the economy is
good this guy's a socialist I think that
contrast for Trump is likely one that
he'd be excited about in a way that he
wouldn't be as excited about Biden or
potentially mayor Pete or some of the
more Midwestern moderate candidates he's
probably right now I do think that
there's a chance that Bernie puts up a
good fight against Trump because at
least he's offering something different
he's not offering a kind of
mealy-mouthed political consensus like
Peabody jej is just such a slime bag he
just speaks out of both sides of his
mouth obviously Lyle Wafaa does that too
it's that Bernie Sanders is the is the
genuine article well look over in the
United Kingdom you know we just we just
had a vote in the UK and political
trends seem to follow a lot there you
know you have in the 80s you have the
two conservative neo liberals you got
Ronald Reagan and you've got Margaret
Thatcher in the 90s you get the new
Democrats who were liberal neo liberals
so you get Bill Clinton and Tony Blair
now you've got Donald Trump and Boris
Johnson who actually even look like each
other it's very eerie uncanny well they
just had their big election and the
conservative the Tory Boris Johnson beat
out the Bernie style socialist Jeremy
Corbyn and beat him pretty decisively he
was simply too radical and Bernie
Sanders likely is too radical life
if Trump goes up against Bernie Sanders
I think Trump wins this Bernie really
did you really think that America is
gonna elect Bernie Sanders I don't know
I think look I think if the election
were held today Trump would win all 57
states but if he goes up against Bernie
it could be a blowout it could be a
total blow it that's what Jim Messina
sees that's what Elizabeth Warren sees
what's interesting about the Jim Messina
comment is he says yeah maybe Biden
would be better maybe mayor Pete would
be better or maybe one of the Midwestern
moderate candidates would be better
he doesn't say Elizabeth Warren would be
better Elizabeth Warren was the golden
child she had the momentum just three
months ago and then she totally blew up
her candidacy by releasing that
extraordinarily silly health care plan
52 trillion dollar plan how we're gonna
pay for it I have no idea but don't
worry trust me I'm Elizabeth Warren I've
never lied to you how I've never lied to
you about how much wampum you would pay
for your health care plan oh wait a
minute maybe I have lied maybe I'm the
most famous liar in the country Warren
is being sidelined she's being
marginalized and she's not taking it
very well she's now accusing Bernie
Sanders of trashing her why because in
some Bernie Sanders campaign materials
they say as your contrasting all the
candidates point out that Elizabeth
Warren has some high-dollar donors she
got some big money coming in and Bernie
Sanders is mostly relying on small
dollar donors
well Liz Warren is furious about this
she gave a statement to the press the
other day she said quote I was
disappointed to hear that Bernie is
sending his volunteers out to trash me
I hope Bernie reconsiders and turns his
campaign in a different direction so
Bernie was asked about this he said what
are you talking about yeah I guess
someone on my campaign contrasted me
with Elizabeth Warren I'm sure people on
her campaign contrast the candidates to
that's politics I've never said anything
negative about Warren because there has
been a sort of solidarity between Warren
and Sanders so far but she's getting
desperate so she's trying to play the
victim as she has for her entire life
she is making a huge mistake here
she was the rising candidate she was
gonna be the nominee when she was riding
in the moderate Lane then she decided to
try to out progressive Bernie Sanders
you can't do that that's not possible
Liz Warren is a race hoaxing Harvard
professor who has lied about everything
from her health care plan to her DNA
Bernie Sanders for all of his faults is
an honest radical he's a kook who
honeymooned in the Soviet Union
Elizabeth Warren took her first sip of
beer on camera six months ago and
pretended that she loves beer and that
she's sort of close to her husband and
hugs a man oh hello hello husband beep
boop beep boop say hello to the camera
would you like a sip of this delicious
beer which I obviously drink all the
time is his own no thank you
this is a foreign experience to me
please keep me off of camera that's Liz
Warren to the public Bernie Sanders to
the public he was singing communist folk
songs with his shirt off in the Soviet
Union four decades ago three decades ago
she is not going to add progressive him
her lane was to be the progressive
establishment Arian her lane was to take
Biden's voters we were talking about
this a few months ago that she had to
make a choice do I go for Biden's voters
do I go for Bernie's voters she chose
the Bernie route not working out for her
all of the very progressive candidates
have fallen apart who Leon Castro
abortion rights for men he's gone
marianne williamson a crystal in every
garage two cars in a crystal in every
garage go on even Andrew Yang who's a
kind of difficult candidate to classify
but he just wants to give free money to
everybody he's declining he's not even
going to be in the next debate Cory
Booker falling apart not gonna be in the
next debate Kamala Harris go on all of
these candidates who were running and
many who were even further to the left
go on so what happens now what happens
now as she doubles down Elizabeth Warren
was just at a campaign event and she
said that
she could have taken the tack and said
look we're all Americans we got to come
together we've got a unite this country
is gonna be ok but we got a lot of work
ahead of us right that's the kind of
people to judge this month pass P Buddha
judge this month is playing the moderate
Liz Warren didn't say that she said that
you got to elect her because the future
of the planet
depends on this election we all know
that 2020 election is not just about the
next four years not just about the next
eight years the 2020 election may well
be about the survival of our planet so
thank you for being here yeah okay all
right that's the planet and it's all
gonna we're gonna have overpopulation
right that's what they told us in the
60s overpopulation we're gonna have mass
starvation within ten years what
happened none of that happened actually
the population of the earth doubled and
everybody's fatter and richer than they
ever worked we're gonna have global
cooling we're all that's gonna destroy
the earth we have a new ice age right
that's what Time magazine told us it's
what leading scientists and all the Ivy
League university has told us yep that
didn't happen we're gonna have global
warming Manhattan and Florida are gonna
be under water by 2013 like Al Gore told
us right that didn't happen either okay
nobody believes it nobody believes that
so what happens if Bernie gets it if
it's Bernie and if the election were
held today Trump would win every single
state he would win states that we don't
even have yet like Greenland he would
totally win Greenland 100% who's gonna
beat him who's gonna beat Trump let's
say it's Bernie I think Trump wins let's
say it's Buddha judge I don't think
Buddha judge is gonna win I think Buddha
judges a weak candidate being propped up
by white yuppies on the coasts I don't
think anybody else likes him plug your
char she gonna win who is club you char
close your eyes picture Amy Klobuchar
you probably can't do it Bloomberg is
Bloomberg gonna win yeah we need to we
need to take down Trump Trump is so
terrible that's why we need to elect a
billionaire New Yorker who's been
vaguely Republican for much of his
life yeah that whoo-hoo that a little
rally the Bernie bro is give me a break
Tom Styer best thing I can say about Tom
Styer is he wears nice Christmas
neckties at winter debates it's Tom
Styer he's like a yeah we need to beep
Trump by electing another billionaire
okay right the biggest weakness of all
and this is a real problem that they're
in it's a real problem especially Bernie
gets it but even if Buddha judge gets it
is if their fundamental partisan
philosophy right now their fundamental
partisan identity is in calling their
opponents racists and bigots all right
that's the only common thread among all
Democrats right now is if you oppose
them you're a racist you're a bigot
you're hateful but it's and they do it
on gender too but it's especially on
race and yet we have just learned that
the Democratic presidential field has
just kicked out all the brown people
they've kicked them all out we've got
another debate coming up in Des Moines
there will be none but white people
they're all white debate hashtag Dems so
white we know that Bernie has a very low
black support we know that Budaj edge
has even less black support Elizabeth
Warren has a little bit of Native
American support but it's only about one
one-thousand thirty second Native
American support Club you are I don't
know I don't even know if they're doing
polls on her only white candidates they
have nothing they're being exposed and
the reason this matters I don't even
mention it just to make fun of them for
their hypocrisy the reason it matters is
because it's so obvious to the voters
the lies are so obvious you know when
Liz Warren comes and says the world is
gonna end if you don't vote for me
nobody buys that even the most committed
environmentalist doesn't believe that
the future of the world hinges on
electing Elizabeth Warren it's just
everyone's whipped themselves up into
this kind of intellectual imaginary
frenzy and so they all not along with it
and pretend they believe what nobody
believes it and it's the same thing on
race when president Trump's black
support is doubling or tripling
according to multiple polls when his
support among Hispanics is high
higher than Mitt Romney's was and then
you've got Democrats who are crashing
their leading candidates have very low
black support other than Joe Biden Joe
Biden's the only democratic candidate
with black support which historically
for the Democratic coalition is
essential and then they say we're the
party of inviting all the races to the
table and yet we're gonna kick them all
out before our debate before our first
debate of 2020 so by the election year
2020 all the brown candidates are gone
that is just so ridiculous for voters
for Democratic voters and moderate
voters and independent voters that you
can't take them seriously you cannot
take those candidates seriously even if
you want to and they don't even have
impeachment here's Nancy Pelosi trying
to explain turning yourself into
tongue-twisters how they impeach Donald
Trump but it's not going to the Senate
so they're going to get them but they're
not going to get them and they want to
hold it and they want to impeach them
and they got nothing Sunday morning
let's be optimistic about the future a
future that will not have Donald Trump
in the White House one way or another 10
months from now we will have an election
if we don't have him removed sooner but
again he will be impeached forever
around the country this leftist
establishment case is weakening it's
weakening Nancy Pelosi has nothing to
offer to the American people these
presidential candidates have nothing to
offer that's why they're terrified
that's why Jim Messina of Obama's
campaign is terrified around the world
the the Obama the leftist approach to
Iran completely falling apart during
that protest in Iran you had a crowd of
people there were there was an American
flag and a and an Israeli flag on the
ground during the protest right so that
the that the people could stomp all over
it in the street that was what the
regime was doing the people protesting
intentionally walked around the American
and Israeli flags what they were saying
is America and Israel are not our enemy
Iran's Iran
that's not what the establishment left
has been telling us for 10 years they've
told us the regime is united the mullahs
restore we need to negotiate with the
mullahs right that's falling apart
all of its falling apart not just in the
United States not even just the case in
Iran in in Great Britain right
you had the brexit vote four years ago
the people of Great Britain decide to
pull out of the European Union
then George Soros leading the charge
said we're gonna have another vote right
you've got George Soros kind of the
leading international leftist donor he
says we're gonna have another vote we're
gonna overturn brexit we're not going to
do it they pour a ton of money into it a
ton of effort into it they try to they
have a the vote in Parliament guess who
wins the Tory who says that I'm
campaigning strictly on brexit then they
get into the parliament and they vote we
just had the vote in the UK House of
Commons on Thursday they passed a law
allowing the country to separate from
the EU on January 31st 320 to 231 now
I'm sure they're gonna try to overturn
it again but this has legs this has been
going on now for four years all right it
isn't just a blip on a map very good
news for the conservative cause very bad
news for the leftist cause and and it we
need good news for the left the
conservative cause because we just lost
one of our great thinkers and because
there's there's a lot of trouble now
going on in the conservative
institutions that we have I mean the
most conservative institution in the
political world you would say is the
British royal family right it's been
around for a very very long time and
we've got NEX it so we got brexit where
the Britain pulls out of the EU we've
also got Mex it where Megan Merkel and
Prince Harry pull out of the royal
family which was a surprise announcement
apparently the Queen didn't even know
about it and there's a there's an
important lesson here for our decadent
inste culture in the in Mexico
it would appear from the reporting that
the reason form exit is that the duchess
of sussex megan Markel wants to be an
actress again a video just emerged of
prince harry trying to get the CEO of
disney to hire his wife
so you can you can hear him he's talking
to the CEO of Disney says you know that
she does voiceovers he says what yes
yeah yeah is it yeah she's really
interested in doing voiceovers and the
poor CEO of Disney is saying okay nice
to see you Prince area yeah we'd love to
try it
okay sure and Harry keeps pushing the
issue she does voiceovers please hire
her please hire her that's pretty
pathetic it's pretty sad someone wants
to quit being a real princess to be a
Disney princess someone wants to quit
being the real thing to being the
impression of the thing on TV and I
think it represents a lot about our
culture we we don't want to do the thing
we don't we don't want to be the real
deal we just want to be actors and
pretend to be the thing I think it's why
actors have taken on such an outsized
role in our culture more so than writers
more so than other celebrities that you
would see in different eras not good the
reason that Megan Markel is leaving
again according to reporting is she
didn't realize that she would be a civil
servant in a tiara she didn't realize
that to be a royal is not just all
glamour it's actually about duty it's
about sacrifice
it's about your country and so they're
trying to leave so that they can live a
life of pleasure again not a good idea
Roger Scruton had something to say about
this
we lost yesterday I suppose the two days
ago he died in the evening probably the
great conservative mind of our time Sir
Roger Scruton he was a political
philosopher and an aesthetic philosopher
and a committed conservative aesthetic
philosopher is a philosopher of beauty
and it's it's one thing that made his
views so interesting is he approached
conservatism not primarily as just a
matter of economics or spreadsheets or
bean-counting or just primarily is a
constitutional arrangement I get to keep
my guns and that's it
he also approached it from the realm of
beauty
what are we conserving what are we doing
you know there was a big debate there's
been a big debate brewing for months and
months now between
serve ative x' or traditionalists you
might call them and the more libertarian
minded people or classical liberals
right and a big difference between those
two is the one approaches politics
primarily from a realm and a lens of
Rights that's kind of the liberal view I
have this right I'm entitled to this
good or service I'm entitled to be
protection I'm entitled to this and the
other thing and a conservative view
looks at politics from a realm of duty
and obligation and loyalty and love and
Roger Scruton advanced that view I mean
he was a really great man he was a great
academic fearless he risked his life to
go into communist Eastern Europe and
establish academic networks there and
try to give people a semblance of
academic freedom I mean he really
practiced what he preached and he took
conservatism beyond the kind of slogans
bumper stickers doctrinaire ideology
that was becoming popular and then 1980s
say and he pointed to a deeper
conservatism he has a quote I mean has
so many good quotes but one of them is
the real reason people are conservatives
is that they are attached to the things
that they love and want to preserve them
from abuse and decay they are attached
to their family their friends their
religion and their immediate environment
they have made a lifelong distinction
between the things that nourish and the
things that threaten their security and
peace of mind such a simple description
of why somebody is conservative and he
was asked once what is a conservative he
said well but simply a conservative is
one who wants to conserve things that
makes a whole lot of sense this led to a
great defense of the nation-state
against the internationalism or
globalism Scruton read extensively about
that years and years before Donald Trump
sort of predicting what Donald Trump
would be or or giving you a little
glimpse of what what Donald Trump would
bring us years before that happened to
celebrate the life of Roger Scruton and
commemorate the life of the man
highly recommend you go on youtube and
watch his documentary why Beauty matters
I think it will deepen anybody's
political philosophy and political
worldview this was a documentary he did
for the BBC it was much more popular
than their leftist document they made to
leftist documentaries to counter his one
conservative documentary because then
it's a fair fight and they never aired
the they haven't continued to air the
conservative documentary but there's a
pirated version on YouTube and it's the
pirated Portuguese version but it's all
in English so it's not a big deal which
is why Beauty matters porque and Portela
ballet is a check it out I think it will
it will be a last parting gift from
Roger Scruton to all of us who are
conservative now and who will someday
become conservative because of the
arguments in part that he makes that's
our show I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Noel's show see you tomorrow the
Michael Noel's show is produced by Ben
Davies director Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producers
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
assistant director
Pavel madoski editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 on the Matt Walsh show we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
you